Shane castas Bear runs it down trying to elude
Jack Hughes and flipped up to cop touched on
forong rake wide now the feed lean cant fires
off the post nearly started the scoring in his
Detroit debut swoops in down the wing off those 99
points he gets forced off the puck by a physical V
shat and here's l back the other way he shoots
at a save B check on a shorty bit for the red
wi Arin serving now cider off for G be loads
one up and snapped it on rebound was there and
kicked out by V back to the goal line Lin with a
shot then Ricochet up and out of play and V Tech
vanage check up to the task get some really
good chances and watch Detroit with a puck
movement here in and around first save by Van
second save by Van regains his feet the wings
go diagonally 51 seconds into this Red Wings
power play for Derek lone second unit out a one
timer off the post from Daniela who was brought
in to do just that thankful thankful would they
go in your favor that's for sure there's one
and we had a second one can't be the plumbing
we'll be back right after this here at the Rock
gliding in down the wing surveying from the half
wall beautiful pass and a save who on toy when
the pucks move laterally as a goalie you may
have a tendency to overs slide if you watch
how it goes there and then back against the
grain for not one but two opportunities then
he does a good job of sealing the short side
post as we start the second with no score Emily
Kaplan what did you learn there during the
intermission yeah during the first period Derrick
lone told me he really liked that period against
what they believe to be one of the best teams in
the league now Mercer in over the line pulls up
drops it back weaving in Marino and broke it up
through the slot heer toward the back door off
a skate and they will wave it off as it did go
across the line but the immediate signal of no
goal position and it's deemed a distinct kicking
motion watch as it gets inside the left skate
of te Meer great if you're Cristiano Ronaldo not
as good if you're playing in the National Hockey
League though we'll be back after this merer
through Center weaving on in trying to connect
with tley red wing spring to it with Raymond with
a burst down the wing feating thry with a shot and
V check another stop he's such a versatile player
and coaches love him so too to his teammates he's
going to time this perfectly surveys from the
trapezoid S one out through the high slot for
Holtz and now guided out by gbear two onone for
the wings here's strong holding beating and and
a check out his piece on top part of the net
brings the fans to their feet here at the Rock
back from Ras mus Daniel strong moving in toward
Ras mus and all the way through Into The Far Side
quter H pitches back around for Ras mus spinning
back toward the forehand out in front vanich tried
to poke it away and it goes in sprung in the Red
Wing score and grab the lead here in the second
they had so much pressure on the devils and you'll
see that P check down low regain possession great
activation by the D coming down the boards
on this weak side and then they just put
this towards the net and when you go to the net
good things happen that's exactly how this play
their sons playing in the National Hockey League
three of them I might point out it's crazy on
this unit here with Jack and Luke unbelievable
a lot fed free from from Lin who is barking at
the referee as he heads off for a new stick
Jack Hugh swooping in sharp angle score this
game is [Music] tied to make a concered effort
to shoot the puck on this power play and they
certainly do that haircuts Jack Hughes High
stepping backs off moider below the goal line
goalies close your side door and if you don't
the elite players like Jack Hughes will take
advantage of that daylight as he did there he's
so agile in the skates he's very seldom looks
out of out of control speaking of skating here's
Jack Hughes on the entry same spot down the way
to the backand Hughes wanted another and it
goes wide he's worth the price of admission
Jack Hughes will bring you out of your seat
stretch your hamstrings every time prior to
his his shifts because he's so gifted and he can
make plays at Speed high rates of acceleration
very creative as well desper brat says he skates
like a magician it's true it's true shot attempts
in the second period 2512 in favor of the Devils
with inside of four to go Chi ahead for Mercer
back to the forehead what a stop BYO unreal safe
BYO new's off to the wing for Smith he lost it to
coer chipped ahead for Hughes
he's got Brad with him Hughes
to the slot he scor sha Hughes has
his second and the devil [Applause]
flee F on their feet here in the credential
Center and it's all in transition quick little
indirect play up the boards by Tyler tooi and
Jack Hughes does the rest oh my goodness the
sublime agility getting separation and
his last hatrick it really first of his
career happened against that Washington
Capitals team last November the 26th so
he's officially on Patrick Watchman digs
it out back to the line cider goes diving
to hold it in skate the stick GIS bear back
to Seer midp Point here's CER on net the save
B check Larin working the goal line gets
it out in front to break it score tied and
two the power play opportunity and now watch
Detroit working this one around you don't see
Alex to Brink KET yet he's over on the right
side of your screen but he is a shooter bang
top shelf Shane gos bear new acquisition was
really good with Arizona resurrected his square
with Arizona Coes I'd say very good good for them
in that power play quarterback type role on the
back end Hamilton midpoint scores and the Devils
lead again here in the [Music] [Applause] [Music]
third face offs are so key Arkin pinned
back there with Heir dug out of there by
holla off to the wing for marino marino finds
SE ther SE ther off the side of the net holl
SC to make it a two goal [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] lead a man Advantage Detroit unable
to do so and the devils are just able to come out
so cleanly as they're able to break out just clean
Zone exit keep that in at the Blue Line back to
the line wman off to the wing trying to connect
with Raymond gets it back from fabry Petri is
out of the box toward the net traffic in front
and poed to by fabry he scores with 33.7 seconds
to go and makes it a one goal game yet again to
keep that puck in the offensive zone that's what
started this play and the wings do a nice job of
playing pitch and catch on the boards watch
the left of your screen 14 and white Robbie
fabry quick hands doesn't even dust us off
watch how quick these Ms are he'll get this
one great effort by fabry as he back toward
van he's out to play it shoveled off to the
glass final seconds take off and the Devils
win the opener on home ICE against Detroit